I was so happy when the story of Robert
Kraft going to the orchids of Asia
massage parlor in Florida came out that
we were as far away from the podcast as
possible I was thinking okay by the time
we get back this will have died down
we don't it's like kind of old news and
weird to be talking about it now because
of every story that we've talked about
on this podcast that could potentially
get me in trouble with the company that
pays my employment like this is it
this is the one that I'm most worried
about this is the story that is most
likely to get me fired so I don't want
to I don't want to deal with it everyone
knows what happened you know what I
didn't want to deal with the suicide of
my friend but I did it keep playing I
want you to go I want you to break the
story down for me I'm a little familiar
you know I don't work for the NFL
Network so I'm not privy to the details
that you are Greg
do your job right now and break the
story down from me piece by piece all
right Robert Kraft Patriots owner was
charged in a Florida prostitution
investigation the Palm Beach State
Attorney released anthony's dancing
we're not using this as our social video
we're not using it as anything he was
charged for two charges of soliciting
prostitution that means he went twice
they caught him twice on camera right he
was male 13 and I believe he ended up
being male 8 as well two times within 24
hours and one of those times was
actually the morning within 24 hours he
went back I was like night time and then
yeah I was like five o'clock this is you
five five pm and then he came back the
next morning before taking a flight that
morning to Kansas City for the AFC
Championship game on the way to the
Patriots six Super Bowl about that
I feel like the Super Bowl is known void
I think they might take it away oh
please like this is one of the there's a
lot of things about this story but one
of the most annoying things is non
Patriots fans be like oh like what how
you feel and now it's like I don't give
a you know it's like that's what's
so great about the story it doesn't take
away anything from the team it's not
like it's not I don't I don't work for
the oh I don't get into sports to root
for the owner I met him once I was
hiking with Jeff Ross and he and his
supermodel girlfriend asked me to take a
picture of them in front of the street
sign that I guess was the name of one of
their friends and Greg's
and Jeff Ross said go Patriots and I
just stared at him ooh
because you know what because I could
see in his face you're the kind of guy
who goes to sex slaves
well he didn't you know so that yeah
that that's the bigger story is everyone
is focused on craft and it's like it's a
bigger operation of that you know
underage sex workers and all that and
that's all serious I don't know how old
they are I don't know if they wanted to
be there or didn't want to be there
that's besides the point
the funny part of this to me is that
it's a it's a massage shack that's how
I'm gonna say it so my mom can be okay
with it it's a massage shack you can get
a half hour massage and a happy ending
it's a half an hour away from his house
he can get people to come to him I don't
know if you guys are familiar with how
the sex service industry works but you
don't know you are - you don't have to
take a road trip they'll come to you you
know what I mean and I don't know if he
was like was in love with one of them
but it's hilarious to me that this guy
went there to do that twice in 24 hours
amazing amazing it's like maybe he'd
never gotten a handjob before that's the
only way I can think he would go back
twice like he was like oh my god
I've been doing it wrong the whole time
I gotta get back to this massage parlor
half an hour away even him I was I wish
I could hear him telling his driver
where to go you know what I mean that
would be funny man well
take take 19 down to that strip mall and
then wait from me for 30 minutes way to
be racist with the driver man well I
think it's a common Florida name well if
I if you read so this is all public
information they released a probable
cause affidavit you know one thing that
stuck out to me was that he hugged the
woman or each time so that would to me
that was the strangest thing about in
the beginning in the end both he hugged
hello
he hugged hello there are some details
you know it has it all written out one
of them included one woman included oral
sex being performed and the other one
actually included two women in the room
it was a repeat woman and and yeah it
talked about massaging the genitals and
the two women that is phenomenal listen
and you guys don't have the money that I
have to be through it was a hundred
dollars yeah a hundred bucks
he can do better like when Jerry Jones
remember those pictures of Jerry Jones
it was like pant like those girls were
expensive that he was with he wasn't
going to he wasn't going to get the to
get a half and a half in 30 minutes or
less I think that all the owned other
owners are making fun of him so hard
right now every every single NFL owner
has had sex with a sex worker I would
guarantee it
oh I would guarantee it that level of
money how about gala then travel Gail
Benson's the worst of all of them okay
Gail Benson I don't want to get into
Gail Benson Gail Benson's getting happy
endings
Gail Benson's getting happy beginnings
Gail Benson for lunch
gets a little happiness alright everyone
knows that everyone Erica and Emma are
beaming with the thought that my career
is ending everywhere
no I I Jerry Jones is laughing right now
what about the Packers they have that
whole thing where like all the you know
there is no owner but you can buy a
stock certificate so there's like
hundreds there's tens of thousands of
owners mm-hmm they have like an orgy
like in the second Matrix movie where
they go to Lambeau and they all just
start riding on each other and it's the
most like why did you do this to us we
love you and you'd be ruined us with
this scene in this movie but it's like
that in Lambeau and then at the end of
it almost in like a santa claus type way
they have money in their pockets you
don't know how it got there
it's 40 fish and bread it's that kind of
thing if we were ranking the fan bases
that you would least want to see in a
stadium filled orgy I feel like the
Packers would be dead last I mean they
would be right there I don't know I mean
I don't know I listen I I don't think
I've ever been to Philadelphia
but it is it's a dark mirror of what
normal people look like so I would think
I would put the Eagles in there you know
but I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure the
people who own stock in the band the
Packers are ugly ugly people they have
it like framed in their family room and
everything of course happy of course but
whoever has the most of those has the
most paid for sex
it's just what you do when you own a
team they don't have to be slaves I sex
slavery I'm against it you know I mean
you want to be a sex worker that's what
you want to do it's a fine it's a fine
job it's a fine job I hope for more
protection for them you know you see the
way they handle it in Europe here it's
starting to get a little bit better I'm
not against sex it's like it's like
they're government tested you know I
mean like if you go through the red
light district in Amsterdam which I'm
sure you will there think they have to
get tested they have to have a
certificate it's like you're getting an
elevator like a yes I get there isn't it
similar in Vegas I don't know maybe
possibly I don't know
I know they're trying to do better for
but there are sex workers who were like
this is my job this is what I do I'm
proud I'm not ashamed of it
okay there's people who have been
abducted and lied to and kept in a room
that's that's way were taken a little
taken a little taking action although
why would you why would you steal an
American girl when you know Liam
Neeson's coming for you when you can
just take you know some of these girls
needs like Russian towns were they were
they they just want a better life and
they get lied to and they're told
they're gonna be a singer and then
they're there all of a sudden they're
addicted to heroin if you haven't seen
the movie Eastern Promises go see it
it'll tell you everything you need to
know about Robert Kraft
[Music]